He can re-write existence and shatter timelines
you cannot trust him I don't care
who this guy is I just lost so much
you thought you could win
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will
be my Ant-Man in the wasp Quantumania video
for MODOK lots of questions about what's going
on with him in the trailer in the movie because
they're using one of the villains from the first
movie as MODOK with a huge twist so we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos this is
just the tip of the spear Kang the Conqueror is
going to be the main villain of Avengers 5 Kang
Dynasty they even tease it in the trailer the new
Dynasty quote-unquote in text so they really want
to start off Marvel phase five with a banger just
to show how worse he's going to be than Thanos in
Ant-Man 3 is going to be the official beginning
of Marvel phase five everything before this was
Marvel phase four but during the trailer there's
a couple of scenes featuring MODOK one with the
mask on and then one without his mask with Kang
as he escorts Ant-Man and Cassie through one of
his portals to a place that seems like it's
overlooking the area where he wants Ant-Man
to steal the device that will help him complete
his time travel platform from the comics this
area here so that he can control all of reality
in when the new Kang Multiverse war and when he's
not wearing the mask he looks just like comic
book MODOK with a massive floating head the
gold helmet around him the big gem in his forehead
the tiny little arms and if you haven't read the
comics this is what he looks like they even did
a MODOK TV show starring Patton Oswalt a little
while ago it only ran for one season because
it was before Kevin feige took over all the
Marvel shows so when he took over he canceled a
lot of those Marvel TV shows quite the big day
sir they're unveiling these statue depicting the
other Statue being made to commemorate the even
bigger statue of you at the center of the city
while you're away we'll have your iron throne
cleaned that was also sort of like an elseworld
spin on the MODOK character because they tweeted
in more of a comedic sitcom kind of way with
Marvel tropes and a bunch of Marvel characters
and stuff going on during it but in the trailer
if you zoom and enhance on MCU MODOK's face you
can see that it's Darren cross from the first
movie Corey stole his character yellowjacket
somehow it seems like he's been turned into
MODOK meaning that he didn't die during the
first movie at the end of the first Ant-Man movie
he defeated him by destroying the inside of his
Yellowjackets which is causing him to shrink
down uncontrollably into the quantum realm in
they treated it in a very WTF comedic kind of way
letting you wonder what might have happened to him
like a lot of people just assumed that he had
been destroyed here like he shrunk that into
nothingness had been crushed like he'd literally
turned into nothing when in fact he just crashed
into the quantum realm and based on the way that
he's floating around here with Kang the others not
being guarded the way that Cassie and Ant-Man
are it seems like Kang might be the person who
transformed him into MODOK the big question is
why he would do that like why not just repair
his Yellow Jacket suit maybe the suit had been
damaged in the crash or maybe his body was too
badly damaged when he crashed because the whole
idea is that Kang wants to escape the quantum
realm would he try to steal the Pim particles
if that was possible yellowjacket was able to
use his suit because it was also using a form
of Pym particles it sounds like when he crashed
in the quantum realm they might have been used
up like for some reason the kang wasn't able to
continue using his technology to escape in what
they're doing in the movie is they're doing part
of MODOK's origin story from the comics where he
asked Kane to turn him into a much better weapon
capable of defeating Ant-Man surviving into
the quantum realm where MODOK starts out as
normal human in then gets turned into this Giant
floating head and this is just the result of what
Kang turned Darren cross into in the comics MODOK
is an acronym that stands for mechanized organism
designed only for killing but he started out as a
normal scientist named George Tarleton who worked
for aim which was sounded by his father like he
was just a normal guy working on the team aim
performed experiments and tried to turn him into
a version of this cybernetic floating head in an
attempt to create a supercomputer called MODOC
with a c the scene is named stood for computing
he wasn't meant to be a weapon or anything like
that they just wanted to create a special super
computer but George Tarleton used his Newfound
power to rebel and renamed himself MODOK with
a K that stood for the killing and went on a
rampage and started fighting Captain America
in his Comics they did a version of his origin
story during the Marvel Avengers game where you
meet George Tarleton when he's still human
and then later after he's been transformed
into MODOK small connection to World War
Hulk in the MCU I just did a video about
the new world war Hulk movie that they're
working on in the background in the comics
MODOK was a part of the Intelligentsia they did a
version of that during She-Hulk but in the comics
the Intelligentsia were the ones responsible
for turning Thunderbolt Ross into Red Hulk they
siphoned Hulk's game of power during the World
War Hulk event and gave it to Thunderbolt Ross
obviously they're not going to do it exactly this
way in the MCU because MODOK is doing something
completely different they've already done aim
with a completely different movie in Iron Man
3 and they've already done the Intelligentsia is
more of a comedic joke in She-Hulk but they are
turning the Harrison Ford version of Thunderbolt
Ross into Red Hulk in the MCU and he'll just have
a different backstory that will flow with the
new characters in store that they don't already
like Val will be a much bigger part of that in
the MCU what seems like is going on with MODOK
during Ant-Man 3 just in the MCU version of the
character is that they're gonna say that Darren
cross MODOK at the start of the movie is more
of a sub boss for Kang that it uses against
Ant-Man and the others like he still wants to get
revenge against Ant-Man at the beginning of the
movie you tried to kill me and I swore Revenge
all these years so during the first half of the
movie he's trying to do that but I believe that
Marvel wants to keep the MODOK character around
long term Darren cross will wind up Surviving
by the end of the movie he'll also eventually
try to help them defeat Kang and they'll give him
more of a Redemption kind of Arc but in a comedic
way like the whole concept of the character Darren
cross total Dirtbag in the first movie that they
clown on for pretty much the entire movie and
that just continues in quantumania but by the
end he turns that around and tries to help them
win I don't know which future stories they want
to use MODOK in but I think he'll appear in future
Marvel movies Disney plus series and they'll just
treat him more like an anti-hero like he still is
a genius and obviously he does have all these huge
weapon upgrades so he is super powerful now but
because they already did aim during Iron Man 3 as
Aldrich Killian's company and they're probably
not going to do Intelligentsia again they just
had to use him during some different villain team
up I think part of the reason why they wanted to
use MODOK in this movie in this way is because
Ant-Man movie is typically more comedic in tone
and they wanted to do MODOK at some point and
he's kind of a ridiculous character like that's
kind of already baked into the character like
he's a Giant floating head so it just seems more
natural to do him in this darker comedic way with
a character like Darren cross like he was already
somebody that Ant-Man clowned on when he comes
back with all the powerful upgrades like you
probably see him in the mass for the first time
like I finally have you Ant-Man and Ant-Man will
just continue to clown on him like it'll still be
funny in a dark kind of way because he is still
so ridiculous like yeah you're more powerful but
you still look really ridiculous and when I say
he'll probably try to redeem himself by helping
Ant-Man defeat Kang by the end of the movie is
because they probably will not succeed like the
whole idea in the trailer is they want to make it
seem like Ant-Man is going to sacrifice himself
because he can't beat Kang he even clowns on him
like oh you thought that you could beat me that's
hilarious and he replies I didn't have to win I
just had to make sure that we both lose like he's
gonna try and sacrifice himself and kill Kang in
the process prevent him from completing his time
travel platform and escaping but because I believe
this version of Kang is the version of Kang that
the Avengers gonna face in Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty
he would have to escape he would have to survive
in some way which I think means obviously that
Ant-Man will survive as well and continue to be
be a part of Avengers 5 or Avengers 6. if you
remember the last couple of Ant-Man movies have
ended with the big twist that somebody seemingly
dies or disappears into the quantum realm like
during Ant-Man and the Wasp. Ant-Man gets trapped
in the quantum realm for just like a really short
time period but it winds up being five years in
normal time in the normal world what might wind
up happening during this movie is that he MODOK
tried to defeat Kang or stop him from escaping and
even though it might seem like they're successful
he winds up escaping Kang winds up escaping and
it only seems like Ant-Man winds up dying during
the movie but he really just gets trapped for a
couple more years until the events of Avengers 5
or Avengers 6. without them completely repeating
the plot of Avengers Infinity War Avengers end
game where Ant-Man gets saved by the rat crisprat
the rat who saved the entire universe the MCU
somebody give that rat a metal there were so many
jokes about that after Avengers end game came out
like seriously it was the rat that saved the MCU
we are supposed to see multiple variants of Kang
in future sure Marvel movies but they didn't say
exactly which movies which Disney plus series we'd
see variants of kangan I think part of the idea
is that obviously they'll have Kang during Loki
season two it might wind up being a different
variant but it'll still be Jonathan Majors like
Jonathan Majors is still featured at some point
during Loki season two but I don't think that
Kang is supposed to be in every single episode
like he's just in some of Loki season two and
I think they're saving many different variants of
Kang like The Avengers facing a bunch of different
versions on screen until Avengers 5 Kane Dynasty
and during that you'll see like a bunch of the
different versions from the comics one of the big
differences though they're treating Marvel phase
4 Marvel Phase 5 Marvel Phase 6 is the Multiverse
Saga movies like those three phases in general so
Avengers 5 and Avengers 6 are a little bit of
time travel but mostly Multiverse based movies
with the whole idea of the kang Multiverse war and
variants of Kang from across different universes
and different timelines but the difference in
the comics is that when the Avengers usually
face Kang or like Kang War for instance the Big
Arc that features a lot of the new Avengers that
we will see in the movies when they're fighting
a bunch of different versions of Kang that team
up together their Kang from across one single
time like his own timeline it's not a Multiverse
based story I think we'll see some of this stuff
happening during Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty but all
these different versions instead of being from the
same timeline will just be a bunch of different
variants from different universes either working
together or competing with each other to win and
we'll see more Easter eggs for the Council of
kangs because I think during Ant-Man 3 Quantum
Mania the whole idea is that this one kang the
Conqueror is ruling everything here whereas the
whole idea with the Council of kangs is that
you have a bunch of powerful ones trying to
work together in equal levels of power the he who
remains version of Kang at the end of Loki kind of
teased that like for a brief period we all work
together trying to Share technology in the best
of each of our universes to try and enhance our
own universes but then eventually a bunch of the
dangerous Kang variants tried to start conquering
quote-unquote different universes erasing whole
timelines and that's when the kang Multiverse War
1.0 erupted the whole idea now is that we're in
like the second version of the timeline so when
we talk about this variant of Kang trying to win
the Kang Multiverse war in Ant-Man 3. technically
he's trying to win the second version of the Kang
Multiverse War because the timeline has already
rebooted like I said at the end of the Loki series
wait till you meet some of my variants and in this
movie we're meeting one of the dangerous variants
everyone let me know in the comments though if
MODOK is going to wind up Surviving the movie
The Darren Cross MODOK let me know what you want
them to do with him in future Marvel movies Disney
plus series like which teams do you want to see
him show up on everyone click here to learn about
the big connection between xiangxi's 10 rings of
power and Kang the Conqueror and Miss Marvel's
Bangle and click here for my full Ant-Man the
Wasp quantumania trailer video in Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!